on a perdu le football est cruel je
pense que AINS va la vie et le meilleur
a
gagné un petit mot s'il vous plaît un
petit mot s'il vous
plaît on rentre à la maison maintenant
on a perdu au tir au but c'est dommage
parce que je pense qu'il y avait
vraiment moyen de de gagner sur le
terrain on a montré on a fait une bonne
prestation on a montré de bonnes choses
mais ce soir ça a pas suffi avec le
contenu qu'on a fait je pense qu'on a
été supérieur à cette équipe mais c'est
le football c'est comme ça il a pas
d'excès de confiance c'est un match
qu'on a plutôt bien maîtrisé en première
période on marque ce premier but là
malheureusement comme j'ai dit après ce
but là nous avons perdu un petit peu le
fil conducteur du match on a un petit
peu reculer ce qui a permis aux iiriens
de contrôler le la possession alors qu'
au départ on avait cette possession
c'est cette possession qui nous avait
permis de trouver des décalages après
qu'on a marqué le but ils ont fait
avancer leur ligne du milieu de terrain
et leur ligne d'attaque pour venir nous
chercher beaucoup plus haut on aurait dû
utiliser un peu plus les intervalles ça
n'a pas été le cas on l'a peu fait en
réalité c'est nous qui n nous sommes mis
en danger dans ce
match ça est fallu de de peu mais ça a
tourné en en leur faveur aujourd'hui on
est un peu on est un peu déçu enfin on
est très déçu même on avait à cœur de
d'aller plus loin dans cette compétition
voilà avec la phase de de pou qu'on a
fait on monta en puissance aujourd'hui
on est tombé contre une une très belle
équipe de la Côte d'Ivoire voilà qui
était qui était revancharde par rapport
à sa Phe de poule qui qui voulait
montrer un autre visage devant devant
leur public je pense que ils ont réussi
on a on a montré le visage concurrent du
Sénégal qu'on voulait aujourd'hui voilà
c'est comme je l'ai dit c'est 11 c'est
ça aurait pu basculer d'un côté comme
d'un autre ça basculer du côté de la
côte d'ivoir faut les faut les féliciter
et nous on va on va rentrer regarder ça
Têtre reposé et avancer pour une
prochaine
mar